the foreigner is directed by Martin
Campbell the man behind the mask of
zorro Goldeneye casino royale' Edge of
Darkness green lantern and some other
films as well that are pretty enjoyable
vertical limit it's okay vertical limits
okay sort of and it stars Jackie Chan
and Pierce Brosnan Jackie Chan plays a
man who loses his daughter in a
terrorist bombing in his grief he goes
to Pierce Brosnan's character who was
once a member of the IRA who is now in a
position of power trying to get the
names of the bomber so that he can hunt
them down because Jackie Chan's
character has the skillset to do so now
this film could go one of two different
ways you could have it be more realistic
or you could have it be like taken to in
taken - Liam Neeson instructs his
daughter to throw grenades off of a
rooftop without even looking to see
where she's throwing them so that he can
listen for the sounds of the explosions
to judge how far away she is and there's
no consequences for this Campbell
chooses the much more serious route we
have a film that explores the political
repercussions of a terrorist bombing as
well as the personal ramifications of
what would happen to a father who loses
his daughter the film only hits a few of
the beats you would expect it to in this
moment we don't get to necessarily
grieve with him in finding this body we
see it through the lens of a reporter
who's there who snaps the photographs
and it's Campbell's continuous unique
viewpoint of story beats that we think
we've seen before and we think we're
familiar with they keep this movie
moving in a fresh way that made it very
interesting for me now I feel I should
warn you guys this is not a Jackie Chan
beat-em-up movie there are action scenes
and there are a lot of fun and as usual
Chan is fantastic in them he actually
gives a very good dramatic performance
here as well he's done really good work
in movies and as an actor I find him
very underrated because he is often
mostly judged for his fighting ability
which is unparalleled and his stunt work
but as an actor especially when he's
given the opportunity to act in his
native tongue he's really good but
this is not a Jackie Chan action movie
only as the trailers will have you
believe this is actually a political
thriller drama Pierce Brosnan has a lot
of really great scenes this is one of
the best performances from Brosnan I've
ever seen he is excellent here and he
gets a lot of really meaty dialogue and
a lot of really intense moments to chew
the scenery with I love Jackie Chan I
really do but Brosnan almost stole the
whole film this is a film that will at
times disappoint people because you're
gonna go into this movie expecting to
see Jackie Chan punch a lot of things if
you want to see Jackie Chan at age 30
that time has passed and so his work is
not going to be the same as it was this
is an older grizzled man who's dealing
with a lot of pain and what I also liked
about the way the film portrayed his
character was that you don't really
learn that much about him at first in
fact you really don't know anything
about him and he seems oddly unhinged
and some of the things he does in
retaliation you're like whoa I mean you
might almost be becoming your own enemy
right now with what you're doing but as
the film progresses and you learn about
his backstory things start to become
clear so the film has a way of peeling
back layers and I found it rather
fascinating the major issue that a lot
of people are going to have with this
movie is that it's a lot more wordy and
I think people are going to expect far
more political as well this is at its
core a thriller and it also has Jackie
Chan in it and so people are going to go
to this film expecting a specific thing
what Martin Campbell does so well though
is revitalize things that need it he did
it with Pierce Brosnan originally in
Goldeneye again with Daniel Craig and
Casino Royale he did it as well with
Zorro who was talking about Zorro in the
90s until the mask of zorro and once
again Mel Gibson Edge of Darkness and
here he's giving Jackie Chan an
opportunity to give a more dramatic
performance while also still giving the
audience a few really kick-ass scenes
that'll make people clap and get excited
but the film can get a little wordy and
that's the biggest issue I had with it
is the mix between is this a revenge
action movie or is this a political
thriller
time's the two don't mesh and don't
really feel like we're watching the same
film when we cut back to Jackie Chan in
the woods living in a tree fort like a
Rambo and then Rebecca pierce brosnan
and political arguing the film is never
boring at least for myself there will be
people who are bored by this movie but I
found it consistently interesting enough
and it reminded me of one of those good
old-fashioned thrillers that we don't
see that much anymore
I'm gonna give the foreigner a B+ guys
thank you so much as always for watching
look forward to tomorrow I'm gonna be
reviewing one of the Friday the 13th
movies my favorite of all of them it's
definitely hilarious 'ti a major guilty
pleasure I hope you guys look forward to
that and as always if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck mine
eyes
[Music]